[Music]
you just finished a Broadway play yes I
did a fantastic run of gore vidal's the
best man with James Earl Jones and
Angela Lansbury and it's it's was
absolutely amazing I mean but the
problem is that the people show up
expecting a little will Truman and this
is the thing when you're when you're a
television star and you're so well-known
people come to Broadway shows to see
will from Will & Grace yeah you know
unfortunately I'm playing a played in
the play such an
I was actually gonna say that it was
actually was actually Morgan I can yeah
that's right you can't no I can't
yes you can yeah but but so I would I'd
go out of the stage door at the end of
the show every night and there's all
these women with their with their
program in their pen and this stricken
look on their face like I like I'd
strangled their cat and I was like what
you did you I said the one to a woman
one night did you like the play she said
he was oh you were great I just I think
I liked you better gay well do so you
find ever-ever sometimes that people say
what they think is a compliment to me
but it sounds you know what I mean it
can in cut well yeah like when you're
out in the world I call the the build-up
beatdown I don't they don't they don't
mean it they that's I went to a
restaurant one night in in Vegas and
before I could say anything the hostess
was like oh my god oh my god it's my
favorite you understand I've seen the
show a thousand times it's my favorite
my absolute favorite it's one I have a
reservation tonight she's you can't you
have right here oh my god oh my god
name
[Laughter]
so what did you say to worry guys I said
you've seen my show a thousand times you
don't know my name and I really read the
credits table under will yeah do you
find that you can I've had a lot of
people come on the show who are used to
performing on television and then they
do Broadway shows and they can actually
hear people talking in the crowd it's
like a distraction is that really happen
like you're there you're in character
and you hear people in the front row
talking yeah and the well yeah and the
cell phones and and the the food the the
worst for me was I played another
I said it again look at that
twice our vision yeah sure about six
years ago it's going to be typecasting
now yeah and and it was a little Neela
Butte play and it's me and for women and
and in the course the play I'm just
awful to each of them at the end of the
play a more attorney walked offstage and
I'm left there the guy in the front row
his wife they've been talking the whole
night muttering what do you say
What did he say and if I sigh finally
she leaves the stage I sit down and
devastated and before the lights even go
down he says well the women were
terrific you're sitting there listening
to this fantastic what a nice experience
you mentioned James Earl Jones
co-starred with you in this play you
know such an iconic actor but that voice
maybe the most famous voice of the last
50 years
all because of Darth Vader I mean it's
pretty amazing yeah and there was such
such reverence we all walked in and when
James walked in it was it was like you
know the the Pope had walked in and very
very quickly he realized he can't stand
that I think it would be amazing if
people must constantly be requesting
that he leave cell phone messages for
him I would think that would be his
entire life could be please you gotta do
it please
he's he's very he's okay with that I
asked him to put sit and put himself on
tape for a friend of mine who was
turning 50 it was a woman but I don't
think he heard that part and I said just
say whatever you want to say happy 50th
there's 72 look pretty the Cameron said
young man you can see a dark side from
here I was gonna wouldn't even care
okay you got my sax wrong